généreuse
mam c'est plutôt la cuisine
convivial
je m'appelle jacqueline ans darche je
suis réunionnaise et je suis en trop peu
l'aude
moi alors vous entrez dans un univers
très hall qui a été mauvais on en fait
mais quelques construit dans les années
60 et du coup il ya toujours bâtiment la
maison principale ma mère c'est de
tradition petits blancs des eaux et donc
mon papa le mélange et caf
mélanger et à l'époque dans les années
50 quand ils se sont mariés c'est un
mariage hors du commun parce qu'on ait
eu d'enfant et ça n'a pas été évident
mais c'est qui
haye a choisi cardiaque et monique que
j'aime me riglaire
et si c'est un lieu de ressourcement
c'est un lieu de
préservation de tradition préservation
de la cuisine traditionnelle
réservation aussi d
espèces végétales le fait d'être
anthropologue lui a donné encore plus
le sens de la préservation de toutes ces
traditions de cette culture de cette
identité créole le praj sur
l'inconscient sur l'homme en génération
l'humain c'est l'humain qui
m'intéressait et l'humain dans son
espace de vie et après je fais des
civils histoire puis j'ai enseigné
l'histoire puis j'ai fait des études
d'anthropologie et du coup j'ai essayé
de mettre mon amour de la vie et de la
nature du moins dans cette recherche
de ses parents me dis pas ça c'est pas
grand chose si tu as une maison
payée tout ni racines à l'entrée pendant
très longtemps j'ai pris goût était mon
enfant sain parce que c'est un univers
comme on voit plus trop maintenant
on commençait à peine à faire la route
goudronnée entraîner dans les wii avec
les voisins les copains les cousins et
c'est un univers magnifique de
solidarité de
de gens qui donnent beaucoup d'armes ou
rencontre
oui si amazon avec du café ce que tu
bois le café en mangeant le riz ou après
ou avant
beaucoup moins
d'argent
le fait de ces lobbys chauffer le matin
je le fais par toujours j'aime bien
faire la cuisine aussi pour exprimer ce
que j'aime au fond de moi est ce que ce
qu'on a pris peu après il ya la cuisine
ya la tradition culinaire et à la
manière d'organiser le jardin il ya la
façon de penser il ya la religion aussi
il ya la façon de croire que c'est
multivariée est en fait c'est pourquoi
j'ai choisi de faire de l'ethnologie à
la cour
je dirais aux étudiants qui veulent
faire des motifs d'anthropologie vous
choisi la dispute difficile parce que
c'est une discipline qui est une science
humaine et on vous demandera aux
demandes de construire comme un
laboratoire en fait observer ce qui se
passe dans le laboratoire donc un groupe
d'humains éventuellement ça c'est
quelque chose d'un peu suivi ristic il
ya 15 ans aujourd'hui audi aujourd'hui
il y a quinze ans et à 15 ans on
écoutait la radio
aujourd'hui une seule posture voilà
bonjour aylwin on arrive ce que
jacqueline à deux extraordinaires je
dirais bon comme tout chercheur elle
participe à la vie du centre vient aux
réunions elle organise des colloques
mais surtout parce qu'elle a deux opus
c'est qu'elle participe énormément à la
diffusion du savoir dans la société
civile elle n'hésite jamais à participer
à des émissions de télévision à faire
des conférences grand public en a fait
il n'ya pas longtemps la bibliothèque
départementale de la réunion montre
qu'on a une identité des racines qu'on
peut pas supprimer en fait un si on veut
couper de ses racines ou est-ce qu'on va
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe les
gens sont coupés de leur solidarité de
leurs assises parle pas que de la rue
news généralement il ya beaucoup de
dépression il ya beaucoup de délinquance
hier
la mire un bon je ne veux pas être
pessimiste
mais je vois qu'aujourd'hui on est quand
même
presque en récession économique
je dirais que ça c'est important de que
les réunionnais prennent conscience
qu'ils ont dans des traditions c'est
intéressant que des jeunes générations
puissent
militer pour la sauvegarde de leurs
espaces verts
cultivons notre jardin parce qu'on en a
un beau hein